One year ago, we arrived on a piece of land
we just bought in Portugal.
We came with one van, on a big piece of land.
With a lot of rain falling, like a lot.
It rains more here than in London, or The Netherlands.
It was raining all day...
And I wasn't really prepared for that...
I mean: it's Portugal, should be sunny...
So, it meant daily wet socks,
and trying to dry stuff, in a very humid van.
There wasn't much here...
We got water from a local tap.
And, this was the toilet...
That's a poop hole.
And, the goal for this year, was to set up a Basekamp.
Set up some basic infrastructure, so we can be here with more people.
So, here we have our first Kamp-fire...
Get it? Kamp-fire?
Uh, yeah, good joke...
Anyway, there was a lot of work to do,
and this video has all the progress we made in one year.
So, the land is big.
It's 10 hectares.
And, at this point, we haven't really seen the entire land.
Only with a drone, because it's really hard to access everything.
Fully overgrown, with thorns.
So, we started making pathways.
So, we need to go through the bushes, somewhere here...
So, we made a path all around the land,
and we could walk around much better.
Wait, let me actually give you a better perspective
of the land, to keep an overview...
So, we go here, the land is here,
and this is the path we just made.
Let's keep a list of all the things we did.
Make pathways: check!
And, as a reference, here's the highest point on the land.
It has a big rock.
This is what the view looks like from here.
Now, with pathways, we can explore much more,
and doing so, we started seeing some things.
Like, over here, we saw a puddle of water.
We got curious to how big it was, so we cleared up the space around it.
We removed a lot of spiky bushes,
and chopped down a bunch of dead trees.
And, while doing all of this, we also found
a few random things in there...
Wow!
A cow bone!
What's happening in this part?
- Looks like burnt plastic...
Also found some more stuff, like this metal...
From a motorbike...
So, now, it's ready.
Okay, it still looks a bit rough, but this little swamp
could potentially be a place to swim, in the future.
And, just for your reference, this little swamp
is located right here on the map.
But, from some neighbors, we actually hear there should be
a bigger water source on the land, right there.
Looking from above, it should be
somewhere hidden, between these bushes?
It's hard to imagine, but when we walked down,
we noticed it does look like something is there.
Underneath these dead trees.
So, we started to drag them out, and clear it up.
Mattia took a little dip.
First swim of the year.
22nd of February.
Be nice and lovely...
And, it turned out to be quite a big reservoir of water.
Before...
After!
And, all of this work is quite fun.
Discovering these new things on the land.
But, it's also intense, because at this point,
we have very basic tools.
We really needed to start setting up our Basekamp.
So, a few months ago, before we came to the land,
we got two old shipping containers.
We needed them to move our stuff to the land.
But, we figured: if we move a container anyway,
let's also turn them into something useful.
Not just a box to ship things...
So, we converted one container in
a fully equipped workspace, with all our tools.
And, the other one, we call the Town Center,
and it has all the basic utilities.
Like, a kitchen, fridge, washing machine, things like that.
So, once we've built them,
we packed them up, and send them off.
They came to Portugal, with some very sketch unloading.
Kind of a scary moment.
It felt like they could fall at any point.
I mean, it's a fully packed shipping container,
on two individual forklifts, and a muddy road.
But, at this moment, they're not on the land yet.
Just in a storage place close by.
Because, before they could come,
we still have to make some space.
So, we currently have the Basekamp
installed on this grass patch.
Where we have the two shipping containers coming.
So, I want to clear up the bushes and thorns here,
a little bit until the trees.
So, the containers can go there, and we have a bit more space.
Which means, yeah, taking down a few more
spiky bushes and leveling the floor.
To make sure the containers are parked flat.
So, finally, they got dropped off on the land.
Luckily, everything went okay.
They arrived in one piece.
And, first, they dropped the workspace, and then the kitchen.
This was a big upgrade!
We suddenly have a lot of tools, and a place to be dry.
We call this Basekamp.
This is the main place, where we'll camp out
in the coming years, as we work on the land.
So, we figured let's make it nice around here.
We started cleaning up the area around it.
Remove some spiky bushes, level the soil,
and plant a herbal garden with some flowers.
At this point, the place looks nice,
and we have this fully equipped kitchen, and workspace.
However, there's no electricity yet, so we can't use anything.
So, we made a big metal frame to mount on top of the container...
We installed the solar panels on the roof...
Installed all the components for our solar system,
and connected all the cables.
Okay: moment of truth, everything is wired up...
Solar panels coming in here...
The only thing breaking the circuit is the fuse box,
so if we put this one on, everything should work.
So, let's see...
That seems to work...
To be honest, this was quite a magical moment.
Suddenly, we could use everything, like the blender.
But, besides electricity, we needed another crucial thing: water.
Because, up until this point, all the water
we use still comes from our jerrycans.
We refill them in a village nearby, and bring them to the land.
But, actually, the upside of all the rain,
is that there's plenty of water around us.
So, we found an old abandoned well on a spring,
on the land of the neighbors.
The spring is right here.
And, they turned it into a well, but it's abandoned,
and not used for many years.
So, we asked the neighbor, if we could
use his well, and clean it up.
And, he said yes.
So, we cleaned up the area around it, and opened it up.
It looks impressive.
But, first, a little swim, you know?
Quality control.
Yeah, maybe not the best for drinking...
So, we asked some guys to help out cleaning it.
Rita asked them to mount a GoPro on their head.
So, they got in there, and emptied the well.
We got some funny footage from that...
And, once it was done, we started digging the pipes in the ground.
We connected all the tubes above the ground,
and we assembled all the parts for the water system.
Which, is using a pressure tank.
And, we installed everything.
So, Rita, can you show the water?
- Yes! The water!
Look at this!
Water...
- It's cold!
And finally, also, a shower.
Well, sort of...
A few weeks later, we upgraded to a decent shower.
So, we now have hot showers...
Yeah! This is good!
So now, we have local water powered on solar energy.
But, one thing missing after six months:
an upgrade to the poop hole.
It got kind of essential, at this point.
So, Ian came, and he built a nice little compost toilet.
With a seat from recycled plastic.
Works with sawdust, and you add a scoop after you poop.
So, at this moment, we have water, electricity,
a dry space, and a shower.
It's quite a proper Basekamp with good utilities,
and it's set up right there.
So, now it's time to work a bit more on the land.
Now, it's getting pretty hot in summer.
But, we have a little stream on the land,
but it's covered again with bushes.
So, our moms came to help out, and clean it up.
Take away dead trees, and thorns,
so we can access the fresh, flowing water.
Now, we have a nice place to swim, and refresh.
We also build a little dam, from the rocks.
And, the water rises, so we can take a dip.
And this stream we cleared, is located right there,
at the edge of the land.
But, what we actually really wanted to clear up,
was a little ruin located here on the land.
It's a small building, built on a granite foundation.
And apparently, it was a kitchen in the old days.
Also fully overgrown, and hard to access.
We chopped down the overgrowing thorns,
so we could go around it.
Cleared the inside, which was, for some reason, full of soil.
And, we took down the almost collapsing roof...
It was really nice, to finally be able to access this building.
And, it has quite a beautiful location,
with a view on the field.
Now, we have one more ruin to clean,
and this one scared us actually a bit...
Because, it's way, way bigger, and way more overgrown...
It's hidden here, between the bushes,
so we invited some friends, to help us clear it.
And, after a few days, we managed to take out all the spiky bushes,
and trees that are grown into it.
Now, we can take measurements,
and make a plan on what to do with it.
You will see more of that in Season 2.
And, here you can see how they are positioned on the land.
Big ruin, small ruin, Basekamp.
So, as you might have guessed, it's right there on the map.
And, by now, we actually became quite
good friends with the neighbors.
They're always driving with their tractors,
seeing what's going on.
Most of them are above sixty,
and they grew up around this land.
They know it inside out...
I don't think they really understand what we're doing...
I mean, we're not even really sure, but they like it.
And, they might be older, but they're still very active,
and happy to help out.
Using their tractors, to connect a wood chipper,
and chip some trees.
Or, help us to move big stuff.
And, they also often bring us food,
which they grow on their own land.
Potatoes...
Fernanda.
The neighbor?
- The neighbors!
Look at this!
It's really nice.
And, in exchange, we help them a bit harvesting,
things like potatoes.
Or, grapes for their wine.
And, besides making friend with neighbors,
we also observed a lot of friends around.
Little birds, that eat our leftover bread...
Caterpillars, that are walking around through our pathways...
Or, slowly eating our plants, bit by bit...
Frogs from the swamp...
Goats and sheep from the neighbors, that eat our grass...
And, probably, this is the friendliest friend...
We have a guest for dinner tonight.
Yeah, they always drop by, to see what's going on...
We have very welcoming friends.
So, towards the end of the year, winter is approaching.
It's getting colder, and the days are shorter.
We noticed something missing...
Up until now, everything was very practical,
like getting water, electricity, a toilet...
We needed a fun social activity in our routine.
So, we made a pizza oven, from clay.
And another essential thing needed for it,
was a roof to keep it dry.
Because, yeah, remember?
More rains here than The Netherlands, or I guess Italy...
So, we gathered some materials...
And, we used some roof tiles,
from the big ruin, we just cleaned up.
And, we built a wooden structure with it.
A roof to protect from the rain in the winter.
So, now we can just work outside,
when it rains, without getting wet.
Which, is a big upgrade, but more importantly,
we can bake pizza all year round.
So, it's now raining, but we eat pizza dry.
Now, this is our saturday routine: big delicious pizzas.
And, the pizza oven is set up right here,
in the middle of Basekamp.
So, we can eat as much as possible:
breakfast, lunch, dinner, midnight snack...
And finally, a last build of the year.
A roof in front of the Town Center.
Because, every time it rains, it gets all muddy inside...
When the sun shines, it gets very hot...
So, we made a wooden structure, with an experimental roof,
mad from recycled plastic sheets.
It's a bit of a living prototype...
We're not sure how it's gonna go, but let's see.
All right, so that was Season 1,
compressed into a short video.
It was quite an intense year, I would say...
A lot of things to do...
It was very raw, when we first came on the land.
All the rain, and just the van...
But, there's something very satisfying, about really starting basic,
and see small upgrades.
Like, the first time we had a cutter for the bushes,
or having electricity, or water.
Really makes you appreciate these basic things,
which is really nice to be a part of that.
And, the goal of this year, was to set up a Basekamp.
To have a place, where we can be with more people,
and set up some basic infrastructure.
So, it was mainly me, and Rita, here on the land.
And, some friends and family came to help, here and there.
And, throughout time, towards the end of the year,
Adrian and Julie came to help out, for longer periods of time.
But, the goal is really to not do
too much on the land itself.
And because, we first wanted to see where we even are...
What does the land need?
What is the plan we're going to do,
before we start chopping down, and intervening too much?
So, the goal was to set up a Basekamp,
so we can invite more people, to come and help out.
And, meanwhile think of a good plan...
And we've been doing that.
We have a Basekamp now.
We thought of a good plan, and that's
what we're going to do in Season 2.
So, in the next video, we're going to show you the plan,
of all the things we want to do this year.
That's a lot, but it's also exciting,
and we're going to be with more people.
So, more hands, and more work to be done.
If you already want to see that video,
you can support us on Patreon.
So you see the video one week ahead,
and you just support the project as well.
That was it for this video! Thanks for watching!
Exciting to start Season 2!
Hope you guys are as well.
And, see you coming Monday!
Every Monday, three o'clock!